الولايات المتحده تتاهب للخروج من عاصفه
القرن المميته لكن غضب الطبيعه يبدو
مستمرا فخدمه الارصاد الجويه الامريكيه
توقعت ان يتغير الموقف جذريا بذوبان سريع
للثلوج في وقت لاحق هذا الاسبوع مع ارتفاع
درجات الحراره لمستويات الربيعيه اعلى
بكثير من درجه التجمد مصحوبه بامطار قد
تسبب سيول وفيضانات
وتسابق السلطات الزمن من اجل تكثيف عمليات
ازاله الثلوج للسماح بتصريف المياه
الناتجه عن الذوبان تحسبا لكارثه اخرى
[موسيقى]
هذه العاصفه الثلجيه التي لم تشهد
الولايات المتحده منذ نحو 45 عاما وما
ينتظرها من فيضانات بالاضافه الى ما تشهده
الكثير من بقاع العالم من كوارث طبيعيه
كلها تتبعنا لالقاء نظره عن قرب على اثار
التغير المناخي التي عاصفت بكوكبنا هذا
العام وما ينتظرنا العام المقبل التقارير
غير مباشره بما هو قادم خبراء المناخ
توقعوا ان يكون العام المقبل واحدا من
اكثر الاعوام سخونه على مستوى العالم على
الاطلاق التقارير ترجح ان يكون متوسط
درجات الحراره العالميه اعلى بناحه 1.2
درجه مئويه مما كان عليه في اوقات ما قبل
الثوره الصناعيه الامور قد تسوق اكثر
واكثر بالنسبه لسخونه الارض اذا استمر
ارتفاعا انبعاثات الغازات الدفيئه عالميا
وافقه الخبراء
وحتى لا نشهد المزيد من الكوارث الطبيعيه
لابد من اتخاذ قرارات مهمه وفي اسرع وقت
للسيما مع تحذيرات
المتخصص بعلوم المناخ روبير افاتار الذي
قال ان هذه الكوارث التي شاهدناها في
العام 2022 مجرد البدايه فالامور قد
تتصاعد على نطاق اوسع مستقبلا عموما دعونا
نلقي نظره على ابرز الكوارث الطبيعيه التي
شهدها هذا الكوكب في هذا العام
[موسيقى]